he is their most versatile defender in
the front seven he's the guy that can
stop the run he can drop in coverage he
can rust the passer and guess what i
think he's gonna be a free agent that
probably gonna get paid
look at him smiling
hey dawg we over here in your pockets
man what's going on girl how's it going
buddy it's going great how about
yourself we're doing okay how'd that one
feel for you guys oh it felt awesome
like kb said it best man we ain't not to
prove anybody wrong we're out to prove
ourselves right we know how good we are
in that locker room man we came out here
played our brand of football and we knew
this was
what was what could happen here what was
the hero what was the game plan going in
because it seemed like you guys kept two
safeties deep you didn't want to give up
the big play and allow your front guys
to get after the quarterback yeah no we
knew coming into this game that you know
for for our defense to have success our
front was going to have to impact the
game at a high level um and you know
when we came in and we were able to do
that you know what i'm saying so
hey there we go
who was that 58
inherit we were just saying with you top
three in the entire nfl in pressure so
where do those pressures come from how
do you think about getting after the
quarterback no i just feel like
this year i'm just like just cutting it
loose and just playing as fast as i can
play you know last year i felt like i
did too much thinking you know
coming into this year i'm just saying
hey man cut it loose play relentless and
that's another like
underappreciated thing about about a
player man if you just play hard good
things happen
and that's one thing you know our
culture is built on that just playing as
hard as you can and you know i feel like
that's what i do one thing coach brabel
really likes about you harold is the
fact that you're very versatile you can
stop the run you can drop in coverage
you can rush the passer talk about talk
to us about your versatility and is that
something that you continue to work on
yeah nah i feel like uh you know i take
pride in my versatility i feel like you
know that's something that could keep me
you know in this game for a long time
um but yeah like versus certain looks
you know i could be the end i could be
an off the ball linebacker an outside
linebacker dropping coverage like you
said stop the run and rush the passes so
hey let's have some fun now let's talk
about that contract
with you
right
hey all i'm saying i love being titan
they better pay you hey what were some
of the conversations what did some of
the leaders on this team say after
derrick henry the king was out
yeah nah i mean you can't replace
derrick man because he's such a special
player what he did for this team but
like we also have that next man up
mentality and you know going into this
game man i just feel like we prepared
our ass off and we came out here we
executed the game plan we executed the
game plan that the coaches gave us and
this is what happens when we do that hey
bro talk about jeffrey simmons too
jeffrey simmons is a monster and to me
he's the he's one of those guys he's a
really really good player but he doesn't
get enough respect
oh bro i'm telling you
jeff a dog
he's a dog now and like
the thing that that people might not see
man is his leadership like he knows the
expectation that we have here in this
culture that you know we have here and
he holds everybody to that standard no
matter who it is and he just put on
display tonight like what he's about and
i'm telling you he's a dog you know and
i'm happy to be able to play next to him
we've see we've heard coach verbal talk
about you as the unsung hero in this
defense would you categorize yourself as
that
hey i just try to do my job at a high
level that high level nine stacks are
already on the season here uh harold and
that ties occur high for you do you set
goals as far as how many you're looking
to achieve in a season
i mean
i'm just trying to go out there and
impact the game every single game and
hey i feel like i'm playing good ball
right now but i just got to keep going
keep apparently it's a long season left
and hopefully we can turn this into a
special year how big has kevin bayer
been kevin byer man he's the best safety
international football league and he's
just making plays like he like he's been
making since he's been in the league
yeah not kb is as
he's as consistent as he comes man he
shows up every single week man
and he's like he's another guy man he's
a great leader in that locker room he
holds everybody to that high standard
and he comes out here and does his thing
every single week and you know like i
said i'm i'm lucky enough to play with
jeff i'm even happier to play with kb
man
give us a sense for coach bravel coach
rabel in the attitude he instills in
this team like give us a sense how he
actually gives you guys that attitude
no i mean he just said it man like
no matter who we play no matter what
time where it's at man
he gives us a game plan we go out there
and execute it and like that's the
mantra that we have man it don't matter
what the situation is we're going to
prepare our ass off and come out here
and play our brand of football and
that's what it's about harold thank you
man i appreciate you all
good luck this season the rest of the
way enjoy that flight back across the
country
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports